[Musique]
première réunion du jury du festival de
cannes autour de monsieur favre le bret
délégué général voici karel reisz
réalisateur et jury anglais biraghi
critiqué jurés italien miguel angel
gurria ce prix nobel est président du
jury
christine gouze rénal productrice vice
présidente du jury
kirk douglas comédiens jurés américains
félicien marceau romancier et juré
français volent tchèquie hasseni
réalisateur et juré de chèques et folger
schlöndorff réalisateur et juré allemand
kirk douglas lui est venue à cannes en
pèlerinage c'est en effet ici qu il y a
quelques années
pendant un autre festival il a rencontré
sa femme anne vous étiez venu au
festival pour la première fois il ya un
certain nombre d'années comme star
bastien et on se presse comme un
pèlerinage
oui parce que vous avez ma femme elle a
travaillé elle ici comme vous savez
comme ça je l ce qui fait de vous être
ici elle vous à rencontrer et vous êtes
mariés bien sûr d'ailleurs je crois que
maintenant toutes les personnes qui
s'occupent des vedettes ou des membres
du jury rêve
vous savez ma femme elle a dit que je
serais trop basse
à ce moment là aussi elle a travaillé
pour moi qu'on peu de temps avec les
fabricants et quelques on a posé la
question est ce que l a travaillé pour
moi dans les passes et le dit lui même
et non le wifi et ou cobayes pour moi
clac de gosse vous êtes venu au festival
cette année comme membre du jury
oui ça ne me plaît pas pourquoi mais non
c'est à dire que j'aime beaucoup de voix
les films mais tout à coup je me suis
rendu compte que c'est bon c'était à moi
de juger les autres c'est-à-dire les 5
mètres vingt sixième de voir les firmes
de voir qu'est ce qui se passe dans le
pays
mais comme ça de juger les autres nous
donner ça doit recevoir les premières
pluies j'ai pas que c'est difficile je
crois qu au contraire mieux s'ils n'y a
pas de pluie c'est à dire si nous sommes
ici seulement vous voir les films de
chaque pays
après le festival vont repartir pour new
york parce que vous avez un calendrier
très chargé
oui d'abord je pars à foug téléphonie
fatigué il in fine on n'a pas besoin de
le faire maintenant pour m'accompagner
avec mon fils ça ou ça me tue la btc sa
chambre d'hôtel abriter et mis les mains
après ça je vais commencer le film le
drôle de pistolet quand je suis obligé
de partir et meriem ans après le
festival
votre fils tu fait ses débuts au cinéma
comment s'appelle-t-il machado et la
bonne foi et il a beaucoup de terrans
malheureusement comme un acteur parce
que moi je peux faire kill kill dernière
ans
réalisez te mettre en scène réalisateur
bizarre mais ça viendra peut-être je
crois oui parce quand il était à l'écho
dans l'université il a gagné les
premiers fruits comme acteur et comme
mettre en scène dans une université
il est il est moi je trouvais les prises
de son et je crois qu'ils travaillent
très bien comme celle là prendre même si
lille où il a joué repoussé par dont
trois films césar j'aime beaucoup que
louis aussi il pense que il est en train
de l'apprendre janvier et pendant que
kirk douglas membres du jury que douglas
producteurs que qu'un doute l'aspect re
re continue à travailler la chasse à la
starlette continue sur la croisette